les gens qui votent front national parce
que c'est ce qui m'énerve c'est que
existe beaucoup pas souvent du décès de
l'assuré c'est cool message s'adresse
toujours aussi violent c'est quand tu
leur dis en tant que spectateur c'est
vraiment très très violent je fais ce
métier depuis très longtemps et souvent
les personnes qui disent des conneries
dans la salle quand quand tu les as le
pag pour qu'elles répètent leurs
conneries soit elles disparaissent dans
leurs fauteuils soit au contrat d'essai
de t'expliquer pourquoi l on dit de la
merde
et c'est encore plus marrant mais si
rare qu'une personne dise une connerie
et la répète trois fois avec avec un ton
assez sec
j'ai pas eu peur de remonter sur scène
parce que je suis pas de nature un peu
peureux mais je me suis quand même dit
est ce que les gens vont pas vouloir en
faire un mauvais glienicke est ce que
les gens vont pas vouloir le balancer
pour entre guillemets pour rigoler et ça
n'a pas manqué de trois dates plus tard
des gens balancer comme ça sale noir
après l'elysée non mais je rigole et moi
tout de suite leur dixième épreuve on ne
devrait pas avec ça c'est sérieux en
fait j'ai vécu un racisme de luxe je me
suis fait insulter sur scène le soir
j'étais à l'hôtel
le lendemain ça fait un buzz après je le
présent présent la république au
téléphone
c'est un racisme de luxe donc ne serait
ce que pour les personnes qui le vivent
vraiment au quotidien et en toute
impunité sans aucune aide sans défense
donc pour toutes ces personnes là je ne
veux pas que que ce soit pris comme une
blague
mon nouveau spectacle qui s'appelle
ensemble ils démarrent par la sphère de
nice où je raconte que
j'étais sur scène en train de vraiment
spectaculaire moment un spectateur m'a
insulté de sale noir à trois reprises
j'étais sur scène avec les lumières dans
le visage et j'avais pas vu à quel point
tu pue ça a été violent mais je suis
resté calme j'ai gardé mon calme toi
parce qu'on ne gagne jamais par la
violence au hockey
ben cette personne qui maquille qui m'a
insulté l'artiste aimerait lui dire
merci parce que grâce à toi on a parlé
de moi partout on n'avait jamais vu
meilleure promotion depuis manuel valls
pour dieudonné mais l'homme plus sérieux
aimerais te dire ce que tu as fait c'est
pas bien ce que tu as fais pas
respectueux si jamais tu n'es pas
raciste
si tu as voulu juste déconné si tu ne
penses pas ce que tu as dit il ya une
plainte qui est au parquet de nice mais
si jamais tu te manifeste si tu
t'excuses je retiens à la plainte
avant je regardais ça de loin et j'étais
un peu un peu fataliste ce musée bas
c'est la vie et puis voilà il faut des
d'efforts des faits des riches des
pauvres et puce est ce le monde est fait
comme ça mais en ayant vécu ça moi aussi
en ayant participé à plein d'acteurs
associatifs
on est au contact de plusieurs victimes
c'est ça m'a rendu très très sensible et
très très en colère aussi contre cette
société
le donnell d'il ya un an par rapport aux
données d'aujourd'hui
je pense que c'est quasiment la même
personne mais avec eux beaucoup plus
d'engagement avec beaucoup plus d'envié
de faire bouger les choses par mon arme
et au delà et le donne elle peut être
bien un an était déjà donnée l'engager
mais qui voulait faire plus et rire que
transmettre des messages
noël d'aujourd'hui à inverser la
tendance il veut faire il veut plus
transmettre des messages que fait rien